now everyone it is nothing short but an
amazing day today
hi my name is Jesse simply Yoshi lien
available immediately my name is Tony
Nicholson I'm a fitness coach my name's
Peter Shankman dear Conchita from Naples
this is not my life now I love books on
home and drop on you when we don't open
our buy button to move move move you
know how do we know why but why waiting
for the money how you betrayed oh we
have to hello
Mulla Mulla not now like I do gonna do
like this nobody in my bio hi Tommy am
the Mira
oh yeah it's been a really interesting
experience my day to day more than
anything else now involves my
six-year-old daughter I'm a single dad
and I spend a good portion of my day if
not the entire day with her if you got
to be stuck at home at least you have to
be stuck with Daddy yeah there are worse
places to be right but thank you yeah if
it comes down to being stuck with daddy
or being stuck in jail I guess I guess
dad being with daddies better huh okay
well that's great to hear
we were on our way to go to Canada right
before the coronavirus restrictions
stopped us to go and that still is very
tough we are not allowed to see more
than one other person for me it's
important since I'm singer mom that yeah
I see people because being together was
a baby 24 hours seven days in the week
during the week this is definitely not
fun I mean it's fun maybe to a certain
degree but it's so hard on the nerves
I'm just watching TV wanna continue
right shall we
I love Shira Hodgins just a wallet soon
put the shots on was the home
I suggest yes she ruled woman in imago
Hadid school yeah but rice but just on a
mobile chain you normally I spent my
days playing board games with an
autistic girl but due to the whole
quarantine situation we're gonna try
today to do it through video chat I've
been in China 15 years I was here at the
beginning of the outbreak and I can tell
you the outbreak the isolation the
pandemic they've all had a tremendous
effect on my business I no longer do
fitness classes I no longer have large
events and all movie productions have
been stopped I am one of the 1.5 million
people who got a letter or a text to say
that they're extremely vulnerable to the
disease in my case it's because I
finished chemotherapy for a really rare
a varying cancer that's also advanced
it's tough and it's affected my life a
lot I would say and I just can't wait
for it to be over and I just hope that
by the time it's over the cancer hasn't
returned because that will be another
hurdle to have to overcome
[Music]
known has the singing taxi driver
I make any life but I see in this song
kappa love song they are all there and
they're messaging me this is the best
part of this this nightmare that we are
finishing the first time I took to a
platform called durian in the West
recall a tick-tock and three times a day
I would live stream on doughy in in the
morning and in the afternoon and the
evening my program called Tony's eight
minutes it would consist of a workout it
would consist of chi gong known as bad
lunch in has been around for thousands
of years in China and meditation so I
would take people through his program
every day because during isolation we're
all in this together right off my daily
routines of course it's doing laundry
yay what's your fun but the funny part
is actually really but mess you where is
he ah there he is
right he's right here so we are playing
we are having fun and that makes
actually the whole thing a lot nicer and
better things they need water for
something exactly ha
ok now the more and more you okay I'm
gonna know now that I own yet this is
our yang you comfy you let me know
look yonder beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
I'll just stumping for it
okay if you want to ruin my documentary
you're ruining my documentary yeah
one thing I like to do on a daily basis
is going for a walk and especially in a
day like that that is really nice and
sunny I often go with my walking sticks
and of course Matthew has to be with me
since as I said I'm a single mom and so
he is right back we got a rescue cat yes
we got a rescue cat which we've been
wanting to do for ages and for some
reason we're putting off asking our
landlord but we figured now's the times
we'll be at home and we got lucky and
got this little fella
he's showing him the Sun what do you
think Wesley
[Music]
whoo-hoo laughs area for change
backhoe new Kota why did hang move back
Hakeem initial attack to mood order look
at now [ __ ] okay you know why I made it
home to Kapil a loom that
moyano the only chance that you have to
go outside it's just find an excuse for
example for to pay this
so with this excuse we'll go outside and
I will show you what is happening
outside this is where I park my taxi my
van we are ready to go as you can see
roads are empty
and this is one of the
very peaceful
so strange see not especially in this
time
five o'clock p.m. of Saturday yep abuse
a substance addict
Atanas sibling ichika i had to sit to
watch game yes any because they didn't
you frozen
this is probably what i have spent most
time on during this quarantine its
football manager and I'm of course
representing my local team Aarhus New
York is weird right now I won't lie up
the streets are empty I'm looking at
Times Square right there 42nd Street
down the Hudson River right there it's
just empty it's just empty
unfortunately I'm very very healthy am i
you know exercise everyday I'm healthy
it hasn't affected me but I've lost two
friends and I have another friend on
oxygen right now and and it's very sad
and I hoped it in soon when I got my
text to say that I'm extremely
vulnerable to coronavirus I think the
first thing I felt was cheated in a way
and I think a lot of cancer patients
feel really angry and frustrated because
they didn't do this treatment they
haven't done these surgeries and chemo
and all this stuff just to catch
coronavirus and die from coronavirus and
yeah it's it's tricky psychologically
especially in my case because i may have
to do another chemo at some point as my
cancer is quite likely to return so this
was supposed yeah this was supposed to
be the year of going out and making
memories so being stuck indoors is is
tough
[Music]
does the question sacrament see ya boo
boo bulya y6y drusy you're watching
scooch up on a kalashnikov epoch oleate
order going to Canada visiting my
friends which I had planned before and
yeah just being able to introduce my son
to all of them it was time beforehand
and now it's even more time to do that
yeah without question the first thing
I'm gonna do when this is over is take
my daughter go for a long walk in the
park go to the playground and ride the
swing swing on the swings in there and
then we're gonna go to Claudia's pizza
on 10th Avenue and 43rd Street and stuff
our faces full of pizza so that's the
goal once this whole thing is over those
are the first things we're gonna do ya
know you might get puffy climbing the
come on with it
we die - by your vagina - put the damn
key a koopa kandy
mom will produce go I know that right
away with after somebody call the
company never do like that concern while
I know the catechol be true
I very much hope that the first thing
we're gonna be doing out of the lockdown
is actually getting married we have a
winning book and it falls pretty much
straight just after the 12 weeks from
when I got my text so that is gonna be
the party of the year would probably be
an understatement if everybody's being
unlocked down that's the first time we
all have our outside yeah if that's
gonna be the first thing we all do I
think it's gonna be a lot of hugging and
dancing and yeah
you